- I'm here with Lisa Rinna
and on the line now is also
Rainn Wilson, give it up.
(audience cheering)
My next guest is a two time Grammy winner
who's single Old Town Road
shattered just about
every record last year,
his new EP is called The
Singin' Hills Sessions Mojave,
it's out now,
give it up for Billy Ray Cyrus everybody!
(clapping)
(rock music)
I like that little lick.
What's up man?
- I'm good, how you doing?
- I'm doing all right,
I'm doing all right.
Well, when, when you were here in March
before the world decided to just turn,
Old Town Road was 10 times platinum
and now it's 13 times platinum,
can you believe it hasn't slowed down?
People love that song.
- It's it's been crazy
and, and you're right
referring back to the last time I saw you
was the last little bit of normal
- Yeah.
- that I recall.
Everything after that,
I left from your couch
and went and did a show with Neil Diamond
and Sammy Hagar in Las Vegas.
- Wow.
- And I caught a Southwest flight
the next morning after
that back to Nashville
and by the time I landed
the whole world had changed.
So it's at this moment to be
back with you going full circle
and we're all starting brand new again
and you're right about Old Town Road.
I think that a lot of
people hear that song
and go back to 2019.
I know I do, I loved 2019 and, and--
- Oh my gosh.
- I know.
- Really any year other
than this one, but yeah.
(laughing)
- Yeah, this year I'm
looking forward to 2021.
- Hey man, your mouth to God's ear.
Is it, is it true you got
your first iPhone this year,
is that a real thing?
(laughing)
- Yeah.
It's a bit embarrassing to bring it up,
but I'd been a little like Fred Flintstone
and realized that my mom
was living like the Jetsons
and I go, man, I'm scared
to death of change,
but I think I really need
to step up to the plate
and now that I have, it's
opened up a whole new world.
I write all my songs now on my iPhone,
it's quicker, it's better,
you can put it in your pro tools.
It's like, I can't believe it,
but I'm scared to death of change
and sometimes that's like that,
but change is the only thing
I think you could really count on in life
and I should have embraced it earlier.
I've sent a lot of
blurry pictures out there
over the last 20 years,
I got my first Blackberry I think
while we were doing Hannah Montana,
I think I remember taking
a picture with Lisa.
How you doing Lisa?
- I'm great Billy, how you doing?
It's great to see you.
- You too, we had fun on
Hannah Montana, didn't we?
- We sure did.
- I love that!
- We sure did, I'll never forget it
and you know how much I love Miley.